oui évidemment bruno examen de faire une
démonstration de force il a il a réussi
son coup de 3,9 et là je produis la
production des images oui bien sûr ça
arrive au qu'auprès du peuple de droite
effectivement et bien ses meetings du
trocadéro qui s'enchaînent et qui
conduisent inéluctablement à la défaite
aussi un ceci sac s'arrêterait là ces
six meetings du trocadéro c'est un peu
l'effet paradoxal des meetings du
trocadéro beaucoup de moyens de très
belles images des drapeaux bleu blanc
rouge est la fin chacun repart chez soi
et finalement tirant la conclusion que
ça n'a pas marché le meeting du
trocadéro qu il a dit hier j'ai choisi
le trocadéro pour laver les affronts de
la droite voilà mais il est passé
le 10 avril ça va ça va à nouveau marche
ça va marcher et puis par ailleurs on
voit que la fonction principale elle est
quand même d'entretenir la flamme chez
les militants qui sont toutes à leur
ferveur sur ce discours de vérité ils
détiennent la vérité les médias mentent
les sondages montrent tout le monde ment
eric zemmour lui à la tribune avec ce
code couleur bleue pour rappeler la
couleur au fond de la droite le bleu
blanc rouge eric zemmour qui lui
prononce le discours de la de la vérité
il révèle à son peuple la vérité il
détient la vérité est au fond c'est
surtout ça et on voit que se joue autre
chose quand même qui est que cette
production d'image du trocadéro va
compter peut-être aussi au lendemain de
l'élection et c'est peut-être du
lendemain d'élections dont ça parle
d'abord et avant tout c'est un meeting
qui s'adressait plus sur elle après 10
avril et bien sûr et il l'a dit en plus
lorsqu un moment donné alors j'ai pas la
citation exacte ou mais il dit on va se
battre pour les cinq ans à venir pour
toute la vie c'est un engagement bien
sûr qui préparé par les 14 pour
l'essayer voilà c'est ça et pas bon il
est pas idiot en demande un rebond
incroyable ici c'est que peut-être on
sait jamais la présidence de la
république va être compliqué mais y
pense évidemment à la suite il a dit
qu'il était là pour s'ancrer dans le
temps
la suite c'est quoi ces les élections
législatives c'est aussi une raison pour
laquelle il tape aussi fort sur le rn et
la suite et 2027 également parce qu'il
faut pas oublier qu'il ya marion
maréchal qu'il a rejoint il ya une
partie de jeunes cadres et de jeunes du
et rennes qui l'ont rejoint et c'est
donc il prépare la suite il a dit il le
dit maintenant il le disait mon avant
maintenant c'est un peu plus assumer
mais évidemment il a un projet politique
sur le long terme et il l'a dit
d'ailleurs qu'il ne comptait pas faire
demi tour une fois qu'il était lancé en
politique nguyen après pour eric zemmour
d'abord le premier objectif d'eric
zemmour en pensant à la pressée
d'arriver devant valérie pécresse au
premier tour car finalement exe mort il
a le même objectif qui est manuel macron
c'est de détruire définitivement la
droite républicaine française et donc
s'il arrive devant aller pécresse et
bien il rédige un seul candidat de
droite en plus militaire c'est ce qu'il
a dit est donc ce qu'il vit c est bien
davantage de ralliement de la part des
républicains et puis aussi l'objectif
c'est d'être le moins derrière marine le
pen pour pouvoir après peser dans les
discussions sur l'initiative sur les
investitures avec peut-être une bannière
commune plus patriotique entre leur
assemblée nationale et reconquérir sa
place comme le candidat à droite pierre
l'a rappelé elle a eu cette phrase je
suis le seul candidat
socialiste oui c'est le diagnostic
d'eric zemmour au fond depuis depuis le
début il souhaite lui qu'à l'issue de
ces élections présidentielle et
législatives une sorte de nouvelle
tripartition de l'espace politique
français une grosse force centriste on
va dire une droite qui souhaite une
droite assez forte au plan de ses
valeurs est assez radical et puis un
pôle de gauche recomposé c'est ça le
pari que fait eric zemmour il ya un
obstacle majeur qui va se dresser
éventuellement sur la route d'eric
zemmour ça sera quel poids la pesée
marine le pen le 10 avril c'est vrai que
si marine le pen se qualifie pour le
deuxième tour si elle fait un très bon
score de deuxième tour c'est à dire ca
l'améliorent son score de deuxième tour
par rapport à 2010 est il sera quand
même très compliqué à eric zemmour
d'expliquer que c'est lui le patron
quand lui-même n'aurait pas pu se
qualifier au deuxième tour et pendant ce
discours un moment eric zemmour parlé du
terrorisme des victimes du terrorisme et
il pointait notamment l'état l'état qui
devrait avoir honte et à ce moment là la
foule présente au trocadéro s'est mis à
scander ça on va écouter
alors plus tard dans la soirée l'examen
a dit qu'il n'avait pas entendu qu'il
n'avait pas compris ce que la foule
disaient que il condamne le fait que ses
sympathisants et créer macron assassin
mais quand même il ya une indignation
évidemment de la part de la de la classe
politique est ce que ça le discrédite
pour la fonction présidentielle comme
d'hier que ce soir qu'à sa mère
notamment en tout cas c'est pas bon
effectivement du point de vue de
l'incarnation de la fonction
présidentielle
celui qui prétend exercé les plus hautes
fonctions à la tête de l'état ne peut
pas effectivement entendre çà ne pas
réagir instantanément la parade qui
consiste à dire je n'ai pas entendu
évidemment la ficelle est tellement
grosse qu'elle fait pas très
professionnel même tiré d'une certaine
manière cette ficelle un peu un peu
grosse donc
disons que si eric zemmour n'entend pas
ça c'est à se poser des questions sur
les cas entre le budget très important
de ce meeting et lakamy en europe et la
qualité de l'installation sonore donc
effectivement il ya peut-être un souci
de ce point de vue là mais en tout cas
on voit que il ya effectivement quelque
chose qui va être marqueur qui va
laisser des traces parce
qu'effectivement cette cette idée de
laisser dire macron à assassin's
d'ailleurs que le président de la
république aurait sciemment exposé la
vie la vie des français est évidemment
quelque chose qui ne va pas peser qui va
pas peser en faveur dans un électorat de
centre-droit qui est un électorat qui
sans doute à des rats certaine idée
d'eric zemmour mais qu'en même temps un
électorat très légitimiste pour qui le
respect des institutions est une chose
importante il ya beaucoup de deux
seniors dans l'électorat ya beaucoup de
d'eric zemmour potentiel il ya beaucoup
de seniors catholique ya beaucoup de
seniors un peu bourgeois asociaux
professionnellement donc un électorat
qui plus tôt est assez légitime
vis-à-vis des institutions une faute
politique ça peut être une faute
politique quand on sait dans à la
fonction présidentielle de laisser
qualifié le président de la république
d'assassins alors après bon moi je note
quand même qu'ils s'excusaient puis il a
dit qu'il n'avait pas entendu contact
est ce que c'est vrai ce que c'est faux
personne n'aura la réponse à part eric
zemmour lui même en tout état de cause
effectivement
c'est très compliqué
d'assumer ce genre de propos qui sont
absolument inqualifiable assassinats
meurtres avec préméditation
donc ça ça bien prendre conscience de ce
que ça veut dire c'est grave c'est un
marqueur effectivement dans l'électorat
de droite cet électorat qui a le respect
de la fonction présidentielle
je vis au corps qu'importe le président
c'est ce respect pour la au moins pour
la fonction donc c'est grave c'est très
grave je note qui s'est excusé
rapidement dont acte pour ça mais ça va
laisser des traces moi j'en suis aussi
gentil aussi persuadé
comme dans d'autres meetings par le
passé avec d'autres candidats il y avait
eu des des choses de la sorte ou dans
certaines manifestations des propos
extrêmement violent à l'encontre du chef
de l'état et en même temps on a senti
hier dans un discours d'eric zemmour et
dans les réactions de la foule
finalement cette forme de radicalisation
il est allé cash alors eric zemmour il
dit moi je suis une seule à dire la
vérité je suis pas un politicien
professionnel je suis le seul à vous
tenir le langage de vérité mais c'est la
vérité ou c'est une droite très très
radicale c'est une droite très radical
qui est au fond on voyait bien depuis de
nombreuses années qu'une forme de
droitisation de la droite quand on est
la droitisation de la société française
mais c'est principalement la
droitisation de la droite c'était à la
fois sur des thèmes identitaires sur des
thèmes qui touchent à l'immigration à la
sécurité il ya effectivement une
radicalisation d'une partie de la droite
ça ne couvre pas tout le spectre de la
droite et c'est ce qui explique la
situation des droites aujourd'hui en
france entre la droite de valérie
pécresse je parle de son électorat la
droite d'eric zemmour celle de marine le
pen on n'a pas les mêmes clientèles
sociologiquement il y en a pas forcément
non plus le même le même ensemble de
valeurs politiques et c'est bien ce qui
explique toutes les tensions qui sont
aujourd'hui au sein de au sein de la
droite mais c'est clair qu'il ya une
partie de la droite qui a clairement
radicaliser ces attitudes politiques
depuis plusieurs années avec ce discours
effectivement qui est un discours me qui
est que le vrai peuple que connaît la
vérité donc ça s'éteint un angle
d'attaqué clairement
on peut qualifier de populiste l'idée
que le peuple détient la vérité le
problème pour eric zemmour d'ailleurs
depuis le début c'est que
sociologiquement quand on regarde son
électorat le peuple n'est pas tellement
là une partie du peuple évidemment le
peuple c'est aussi les catégories
favorisées évidemment mais le peuple au
sens que eric zemmour veut viser c'est à
dire la réunion d'une partie de la
droite catholique traditionnelle et des
classes populaires pour le moment cette
alliance n'a pas pris
[Musique]